c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche parce que on a mal cherché
au départ au mauvais endroit
on les a sous le nez et pourtant on est
passés observateurs non c'est faux en
fait on ne se rend pas compte qu'on
sorte les meubles avec ses pompes parce
que on passe son temps en fait à mais
c'est pour ça qu'on voit des chaussures
pour se protéger des pieds c'est l'une
des particularités de la nature c'est de
protéger d'enveloppés sont dieppe
[Musique]
[Rires]
le mot abréviations il est sinon
partirai pas cours
[Musique]